My name's Chris Morel and
I work in social media marketing and
concept marketing for
the last ten years or so for
brands including FitBit, Clif Bar, Sony
PlayStation, and now here at Edacity.
When you're setting
up your ad campaigns,
it's really important to think about
what keywords you're going to target.
So if you're developing a fitness app,
it might not make sense to
target fitness as a keyword,
because it's really competitive and
might be really expensive.
It might make sense to target a phrase
like hit the gym, or go outside,
or something that might get you a little
better return, because the cost is low
and it's a little less
competitive with bigger brands.
You have to get creative
with keywords and ad terms.
Five, six years ago, when these social
channels were really getting off
the ground,
things weren't quite as expensive.
It wasn't a lot of competition
with big brands, but
now everybody's advertising on social,
so you have to start getting a little
bit creative with the keywords and
your campaigns to get better returns and
to compete against people that might
be advertising the same words as you.
>> When we're thinking about acquiring
new customers, we definitely want to
make sure our key words are really
targeted to your audience, so
you want to keep them long-tailed too.
If you start bidding on really broad
terms, where we're thinking more
father up in the buying cycle or
the buying funnel, right?
So you want to be capturing a user
who's about ready to download an app,
for example.
So maybe, for example,
it's a music app or music streaming app.
You don't want to be targeting users
who are looking for Taylor Swift or
Taylor Swift music.
That's going to be too broad,
and most likely,
they're not going to be as likely
to convert or download that app.
So you want to be thinking really
specific, like music streaming app,
or listen to Taylor Swift
music on my phone, or
Taylor Swift music app,
something like that.
So you want to get really down to those
long tail terms when you're acquiring
new users off search because you want to
think about how people behave on search,
both google.com and Google Play.
They know what they're looking for,
and so
you want to be present only when they're
most likely to download that app.
The other thing you want to keep
in mind is making sure your
ad creatives are relevant
to your keywords.
So if I'm searching for Taylor Swift
music, ideally I see an ad that
says listen to Taylor Swift
music 24/7 or something.
So having that relevancy really makes it
more likely that your ad will perform,
that it'll drive more downloads,
capture the user's eye, and
you also want to make it clear what
the action is, so in any ad creative,
you want to say download today or
download the app now.
Something really simple like that where
the user knows if I'm going to click on
this ad, it's going to be very
clear what the action is.
And it'll make it easy for
me to download the app or
register for your product or
your service.
So yeah, those are the things you
want to keep in mind is keeping
the keywords in the ads relevent and
then ultimately the landing page.
So obviously if I'm looking to
download or stream music or
sign up today,
hopefully when I click that ad,
it takes me to the registration
page where I can register for
your product, or
I can download that app right then.
So the most ideal experience would,
say on my phone,
I'm going to search on my phone and
listen to Taylor Swift music on an app,
see your ad, click on the ad,
then it takes me to Google Play Storem,
and I can download the app and
start then using it.
AdWords function as an auction,
so if a user is looking for
a certain type of product, usually
they're going to see multiple ads, and
you might wonder how do I make sure
that I show in the top position, or
at the top of the page,
or even on that page.
So all of that comes down to how
well your campaigns are set up, so
you want to follow those principles
that we've been talking about and
have really tightly themed keywords
that are most relevant to your product,
keep your ads really
relevant to your keywords,
and then ultimately your landing
page is really relevant.
So all of that comes into play, but then
ultimately, you can use your bid to,
so this would be how much you're willing
to pay for a user to click on your ad.
So there are a number of factors
that determine which place your
ad is within the auction.
So which position your ad will
be within the Google results.
Two of those main factors that we
know of, it is an algorithm so
we don't know all the factors that go
into play, and that's part of Google's
secret sauce is just keeping it fair so
that no advertiser,
one advertiser can play the system, and
know how to place their ad at the top,
but we want to make sure the best ads
are showing for every search query, so
the way that we determine that
as Google is two major factors.
One is quality score and
the other is your bid.
And so quality score,
we'll talk about that first.
It's a score that combines
the quality of your ad, and
the quality of your keywords, and
the quality of your landing page.
So that's why we talked about why
those three are so important in your
campaign set up, because you really
want to make sure you have a quality ad
that really is descriptive of what your
business is, of what your product is.
And that the landing page does
actually direct to your business.
So all of that goes into play
in creating a quality score,
which is attached to every
one of your keywords.
So then when a user searches
a term that triggers your keyword,
that quality score comes in to play.
As long as everything is in place and
you have a high-quality setup,
then the next thing that the auction
will look at is your bid, and
your bid is how much are you
willing to pay per click.
Now every advertiser can set that
individually per keyword and
say I'm willing to pay,
let's say I'm willing to pay $0.30 for
a user to click on this ad.
Now maybe my competitor is willing
to spend $0.20 for a click.
Now my competitor might have a lower
quality score than I do and
in that case,
the combination of the quality score and
the bid will win out the auction.
So the advertiser will get the first
position with the best quality score,
and the best bid.
Now as far as bidding goes, you only
have to pay the amount that'll win
the auction or beat out the next
advertiser competing with you, so
if my competitor was bidding $0.20, I
was bidding $0.30, but I had the better
quality score, I'll only have to pay
$0.21 to beat out that other advertiser.
That's why Google functions as
an auction to make it more fair for
advertisers to decide how much
are they willing to pay, but also,
you don't have to pay more than
the market price per click.